oh my god the last freakin two hours
underwear for the damn traitor to drop
marbles the defenders official trailer
number two a couple of things one heads
up I'm going out of town to Colorado for
a wedding and I won't be able to watch
the defenders because this is the
weekend of the defenders but you best
believe when I get back I'm doing a
review because this is the most
anticipated show of the entire year for
me
- totally jumbled I did not forget your
shout out for patron the day let's do
this the thing about war is it only
works if both sides believe every good
gun yeah yeah so different we fight to
get back what was once any rate yeah but
in the end I miss anything it's just a
city you'll get used to watching them
fall oh now she's controlling a lecture
on linguistics - we need to figure out
our next next and there is no we what is
that we're not here to eat those porks
no I'm a shrimp oh this guy's got pork
God your marriage look at the super
plates
I don't know can't fight these people
not even with whatever does your hand
can do it's cheap it's not the hunting
of friends or family and I'm knocking
down sir
sorry Trish Oh God more Casas curry
there
the only thing keeping Manhattan from
Kremlin to a pile of dust just the four
of you
the boys are New York silver
nor yet yeah boy whoa good idea I can be
formed a kind of song I promise you with
timber
they will disappoint you
Jessica like you're in the party
I'm out there together
glad we found each other oh my god
yeah I've been like just anxiously we I
haven't left this room in two hours I've
just been like I want to be here right
when it drops on the notification oh man
my heart is like beating so fast I was
so excited for that oh gosh I gotta go
watch dunkirk and like a half hour and I
don't want to get 300 up so I can't
really talk about it too long I mean
there's just so much to look forward to
here I've heard a lot about what the
dynamics in the chemistry are going to
be for these characters is going to be
like a cat-and-mouse game between
Jessica Jones and Matt Murdock Luke Cage
is going to be sort of a mentor role for
Danny Rand and the relationship is going
to be inspired by the Heroes for Hire a
comic storyline you know Power Man and
Iron Fist and I'm so excited for this
show because the way how it left off for
each one of these people especially you
know jessica jones ultra loner strong
woman
i really feel like she's gonna have a
hard time deciding to work with three
men who probably think they have a
leadership authority over her in some
capacity Danny ran after the events of
iron fist being great because Phil I
could be him for haul away with my curly
hair maybe I'd rather be Jon Snow anyway
but Danny ran after the events of iron
fist he probably has a lot of trust
issues in terms of working with people
Luke Cage you know he does I heard that
when it comes to Matt Murdock it's
picking up just a little bit after the
events of daredevil season two but he's
not really engaged into being a
vigilante right now and he himself
already has a hard time working with
people so they've established these four
characters who are in positions right
now where they're not the best at
working with people so I like that kind
of heroic team-up chemistry where these
heroes are used to working alone or
prefer to work alone and now they're
going to have to learn to trust each
other over the course of this season and
it seems like there's going to be some
really fun banter some fun disagreements
and some awesome heart and camaraderie
when these four are coming together
really
learning to work as a unit and being
able to play off each other's strengths
Sigourney Weaver as the villain of this
show I mean how can you not be excited
for Sigourney Weaver to be in this if
you are all familiar with Sigourney
Weaver's filmography especially her
biggest hit she's a perfect type of
person to play a female antagonist I
find that very fascinating how she's
controlling or manipulating something
with Elektra and I keep wondering how is
that going to play on the emotional
turmoil of a lecture us is the aspects
of life and the personality then that
Murdock fell in love with Elektra for is
any of that still president her and I'm
sure he's going to be doing a lot to try
to keep bringing that slide out of her
because that's Matt Murdock that's his
style and already with just that bit of
knowledge because daredevil most likely
going to be the main leader of the
defenders going up against this enemy
and one of the enemy's biggest strengths
and leverage is the fact controlling
Elektra a little extra just as a lethal
warrior even if she didn't know Matt
Murdock is a threat because she's a
lethal assassin but because of the
emotional connection she has with Matt
ah is going to be an epic series and
beyond just the main defenders you know
you saw Trish in the trailer you got to
see foggy
you know Claire's in the show there was
a brief image of stickey's talking with
the defenders as the steamer is also
talking with Sigourney Weaver so what is
stick really up to here is you really on
the defenders side there's a shot there
with Madame Gao and Sigourney Weaver's
Alexandra talking with each other
they're probably working together
villains are teaming up heroes are
teaming up all the character all the
side supporting characters are coming in
and she looks great between the guys the
boomers like I'm not hugging you Jessica
Jones Tessa daredevil nice ears and he
says they're horns and the cool thing is
like I don't feel like the humor will
feel forced because they've shown in the
show that all these characters have a
sense of humor in their personalities
they're not like the hilarious people
but you know the personality sides of
them that have humor is going to be
great shut up the car alarm shut up I'm
filming yeah I was just like having an
anxiety attack watching that I was my
heart which is beating so fast I'm like
dude slow your heart down so you can pay
attention to what's going on the
terrific I'm super jacked for this I
know there's probably an infinity war
trailer even coming out tomorrow and
justice lee and all these other big
but this is the one I'm looking forward
to the most and I can't wait till this
comes out and of course totally jumbled
pay turn of the day shout out to you
buddy
totally jumbled head we're talking her
to Google hangout over on patreon this
guy's going to be a father in November I
believe he's having a baby girl and
totally jumbled if your daughter is
watching this in the future one day I
want you to know I'm your real father
TJ is not your debt this guy
unfortunately TJ is a much better
looking guy than me but hey I figure
this is the best way for you to know the
truth of the matter and I don't love you
that's why TJ is going to raise you
instead but I do love your mother and if
she's watching I miss you anyway guys
subscribe to the real rejects are my
thoughts are just kind of all over the
place there was discovery the real
rejects click the notification bell and
follow us at patreon.com slash the real
rejects so much love over there I'm
having the greatest time hanging out
with the community there much love I
gotta go watch dunker